welcome everyone to Long crime daily I'm
your host Brian buckmeyer we begin with
news out of Wisconsin where a walker
should judge once again order defendant
Daryl Brooks out of the courtroom after
she says he's making a mockery of Court
proceedings Brooks faces 77's charges
stemming from the deadly Waukesha parade
crash last November six people were
killed and dozens more injured when
prosecutors Say Brooks rammed his SUV
into the annual holiday parade Brooks
has made a national headline since then
after moving to represent himself in the
trial claiming to be a sovereign citizen
presiding judge Jennifer Darrow has
called for his removal from the
courtroom multiple times noting he
interrupted proceedings on Thursday
within the first minutes of Court when
Brooks was again ordered out of the
courtroom he removed his shirt judge
Darrow noted he also took off his shoe
and was aggressive with Court deputies
Brooks's actions have called into
question his mental competency but
prosecutors believe it's an act of
defiance
these are deliberate actions on his part
as we get closer and closer and closer
to actually presenting this case to a
jury that he is attempting to derail
these proceedings and avoid the
inevitable
and I want to make that record I tell
this court as an officer of the Court we
have zero concerns as to the mental
competency of Daryl Brooks to proceed
and we have had many many dealings with
him on the record and off the Record
that I base that on
judge Darrow backed prosecutors saying
multiple competency exams have already
been performed arguing his actions are a
conscious decision to interrupt
proceedings
Discord has read through not one not two
not three but four evaluations related
to the special plea that was withdrawn
and those are very recent evaluations
where the examiners
um
met face to face in the jail or in a
appropriate visitation room with Mr
Brooks either in July or August of this
year and every single one of those
individuals did a mental status exam
that's noted in their reports frankly
the behavior that we're starting to see
here is no different than some of the
behavior that was noted by those
examiners as well that this behavior is
frankly more in line with someone who's
defiant deliberate and in line with the
conclusions related to whether he
suffers from a mental disease or defect
that would qualify for a special plea it
is the sole intent of Mr Brooks to make
a mockery of this process
and I've stated and I'll state it again
I'm not going to tolerate it but there
is uh I believe this trial needs to
continue
joining us today is legal analyst
Matthew mangino and co-host Terry Austin
Matthew you can't tell me that it won't
be at least argued that a shirtless
Brooks isn't competent to stand trial is
there any way this case doesn't get
wrapped up in appeal after appeal
well Brian I don't see any uh way around
it I mean this this case is certainly
going to be one that's going to be
scrutinized by an appellate court I
think that the judge is doing the best
that she can to keep control of her
courtroom but you have what appears to
be a defendant who's defiant a defendant
who
doesn't want to follow the decorum of
the Court a defendant who wants to be
disruptive who wants to make a point I
mean it lends itself by his very conduct
taking off his shirt uh you know turning
his back to the court that you know is
he competent can his competency change
from a a uh an evaluation that was done
in the past to the current time I mean
these are all issues this court has to
deal with yeah and of course I think we
got a correction his name is Darrell
Brooks he's asked the judge to pronounce
it that way but Terry what do you think
the jury is thinking about this at this
point about Brooks and about the process
of criminal trial in general
you know the whole trial at least for
when the jury came in began with him in
that adjacent courtroom so the first
thing they're probably thinking is why
is he in another room why is he wearing
a jail uniform and the judge was very
careful not to say that he was
disruptive but she did in her jury
instructions she stated that when you
have someone who is disruptive they can
you know obviously deal with that as far
as the Court's concerned and then she
mentioned well Brooks is in the other
room so I think they can come to that
conclusion that he's being disruptive
and he's not following the rules of the
Court yeah and they'll probably see it
as his case continues that disruption
that he's putting forward in front of
the court probably not going to help his
case well still ahead on Long crime
daily we continue our complete coverage
in the Waukesha parade Massacre trial
the judge allows Brooks back inside the
courtroom but not without an argument I
see the pair Clash once again after the
break
foreign
[Music]
welcome back after an eventful morning
in the walkship parade crash trial judge
Jennifer Duro gave Brooks the
opportunity to return to the courtroom
for the afternoon reading of jury
instructions again Brooks refused to
stop when judge Jerome instructed him
not to interrupt she said his actions
are a stalling tactic
if you keep interrupting me then you
will forfeit your right to be present
because you're showing through your
conduct that you will not follow the
most simplest Rule of Civility in a
courtroom and that's by not interrupting
you continue to interrupt it's been a
couple of minutes since we've been on
the record and there's been a number of
times you've already interrupted me you
claiming to not understand and you
wanting to discuss subject matter
jurisdiction do not
um
it's just it's just a tactic by you the
fact that you are uh doing that
demonstrates to me that you came back
over here
right with absolutely no intention of
following the rules the ongoing argument
continued even as jurors were brought
into the courtroom
I still would like to ask questions
stop talking we are proceeding with the
continued advisement to the jury of
these preliminary jury instructions do
not interrupt me the record should
reflect that the jurors are entering the
courtroom
Mr Brooks
stop talking it's not appropriate at
this point in time
you'll have opportunity later to raise
other issues but the issues that you
seek to engage with this court are
issues I've already addressed you have
not you have not shown uh Mr Brooks
in the courtroom I don't understand that
you continue to talk despite being told
to sit down and to pay respect to this
court to these jurors to the process it
is my right to stand or to save your
honor is my right
you can stand you need to be quiet
opening statements finally began a late
Thursday afternoon we'll break down what
happened on the next episode of Law and
crime daily
Terry what options does the judge have
when dealing uh with a disorderly
defendant and why did she allow Brooks
back into court
you know that's a great question under
Wisconsin law she has several options
for someone who is quote stubbornly
defiant and he was stubbornly defined he
is still competent as far as we are
concerned but she can hold him in
contempt she specifically said she did
not want to do that she wanted to give
him an opportunity to be in there and
she gave him every opportunity and I
absolutely think when that jury came in
when they saw how he was behaving if
they had some question before as to why
he was in another room it was clear to
them because he was disrupting every
part of the process she allowed him to
come back because one of the things she
said was listen if you can promise you
will abide by the rules and you will be
considerate then you can come back in so
every part of the process she's giving
him that opportunity she said come back
in for the rest of these jewelry
instructions but as you saw he still is
not listening so she's trying to do her
best not to be reversed on appeal yeah I
mean that seems like the goal here Matt
is there logic behind this chaos is
Brooks just looking for a mistrial or is
this just a man that clearly cannot
represent himself
well you know I I think I mean if there
was logic behind this he'd be trying to
present some cogent defense uh on his
own behalf or even better he'd have
representation of legal counsel
competent legal counsel I I'm not sure
what the end game here is uh for for
Brooks it's just delay uh you know so if
if he can prolong this process if maybe
he can get a mistrial if he can get some
sort of uh delay it's just putting off
what's ultimately going to happen here
you know he's not going to walk out of
this uh courtroom without there being a
verdict uh you know unless that verdict
is not guilty and I see I think that's
extremely unlikely he probably thinks
it's extremely unlikely and that's why
he's in this process of just trying to
be uh disruptive uh trying to get to to
to delay and it really I don't see as
having any real logic behind it other
than I'm facing a lot of time and I'm
just gonna do whatever I want to do in
this courtroom yeah and don't forget
he's starting to do this in front of the
jury not the smartest of moves well
switching to the West Coast the
California family is found dead after
going missing earlier this week
a Manhunt ensued after the family of
four including an eight-month-old her
mother her father and her uncle
disappeared Monday morning a few hours
later one of the family members vehicle
was found Ablaze that led law
enforcement to determine the family was
kidnapped and forcefully taken a
gunpoint from their own trucking
business authorities announced late
Wednesday the bodies of the children of
the child and three adults were found
dead in an orchard 48 year old Jesus
Manuel Salgado who has a criminal
history was taken into custody Tuesday
police say he attempted suicide before
his arrest and was hospitalized in
critical condition they say other
suspects May have also been involved
officials believe the crime may have
been financially motivated
coming up on lawn crime daily closing
arguments are presented in Alex Jones's
second Sandy Hook defamation trial plus
what Parkland school shooter penalty
phase trial a rebuttal witness refutes
to defend his narrative but will that be
enough to sway the jury
[Music]